who made your clothes modern-day
consumers are increasingly conscious
about what they eat and drink but what
about what they wear que nosotros
tengamos tiendas contrabass tremenda
mente virata's significa que el trabaja
dork a estado con sergio Nando's aprenda
esta cobrando muy poco y seguramente
tenga muy poca seguridad aboard al
seguramente sin condiciones de cine
slava to seguramente no hay ningún tipo
de seguridad en los localize unas raha
this 18 year old was throwing clothes
for brands such as Benetton mango or
Primark when her factory in Bangladesh
collapse she miraculously made it alive
after 17 days buried in the rubble the
Rana Plaza disaster claimed more than
1,100 live and went down in history as
the worst accident of its kind sparking
many companies to promise better
diligence a promise that is not enough
from MEP si si no tenemos una Marco
obligatorio vinculin Tay I muy claro de
como esta siempre sistema to comport RC
y lo dejamos a la voluntad de las
empresas nunca hemos alcanzar el
compromiso rial de que service potential
los restos monosyllabic raleigh's y
sociales de los trabajadores mep is on
the development committee want uterus
labels for sustainable clothing and
rules that force actors to be socially
responsible from the first weaves down
to the last stitch
[Music]